Dude, how much time do we have here?
Come on, man. Look here. Here's the
bottom line.
Did you catch it? Here's the bottom
line. I love that. That's a speaking
technique. It's called a summary prompt,
and it's just one of the speaking
techniques that Barack Obama uses in his
interview with Hassan Minaj, and it's
what we're going to analyze here today.
Why is Barack so interesting to listen
to? We're going to cover four techniques
that you can use in your work and
personal life. My name is Michael. I'm a
public speaking coach and I'm one of the
creators of the Ultra Speaking Method.
And by the end of this video, you're
going to have things that you could use
on the fly whenever you're speaking off
the cuff to be more clear and more
interesting to listen to. So, let's
break it down. Number one, Barack Obama,
you just saw it. He uses this thing
called summary prompts. And these are
little prompts for your brain and for
the listener's brain to send one
specific signal. And it's this. I'm
about to give you the message. So, let's
see it in action.
I guess this is the point I'm trying to
make. The point you're making though is
a legitimate the point I was going to
make here. Here's the bottom line.
All he does the entire interview is say
things like bottom line, the point I'm
making, I guess what I'm trying to say
is he has a habit of summarizing often.
And this is one thing we've noticed that
all the great speakers do. They
summarize their message often. All
right. Number two. Number two, and this
is related. Brock doesn't just give you
the message, he shows it to you. He
brings it to life and he uses a couple
of techniques, but mostly analogies and
examples.
Let me give you a specific example.
Here's an example. Take an example like
here's another way of saying it.
Here's another way of saying it. That's
what he does throughout the entire
interview and it's so effective. He like
all great communicators know that
there's no one way of explaining
something. So, he's constantly trying to
show you different ways of seeing an
idea. He uses examples. He uses
analogies in hopes that you can picture
what he's saying. And let's take a look
at one of my favorite analogies that he
uses in the interview. He's asked about
the human condition and he decides to
talk about it using chimps and bananas.
We're a bunch of chimps
with guns and
big machines.
Yeah. Talk that talk. But we're basic
but we're basically still operating at
chimp-like levels. And it doesn't matter
if you have enough, you know, you got a
banana. Somehow you still want everybody
else's banana.
When you use examples and analogies,
you're doing your listener a favor.
You're saying, "Let me paint the picture
for you." And it becomes much more
interesting to listen to. The bottom
line is that great communicators don't
just tell you something. They find
different ways to show you. And what's
great about this 30inut interview is
that throughout the 30 minutes, Barack
is constantly in the habit of thinking,
how else can I explain this idea? And
that's really what great communicators
are constantly doing. Okay, number
three. Let's jump to it. So far, we've
talked about what makes him so clear and
so vivid, but what is it that makes him
personable? From my vantage point, the
one thing that Barack does really well,
and all great speakers do, is he's very
open. He's very vulnerable and I want to
play for you one of my favorite clips
from the entire interview where he
shares one of the dreams he had while
being in the White House. And it's just
not something that I would have expected
from a president to share with the
world. But take a listen. I did have
dreams where I wasn't president and they
were some of my happiest dreams where
I'd be walking down the street and you
know it was a nice day and and I'd stop
and get like in a little bodega I'd stop
and get like a
ice ice coffee or something
and I'd sit on a bench and suddenly I
realized nobody recognizes me
and I that's the only thing that would
happen in the dream. I'd just be sitting
there chill and I I felt I felt like I
had won the lottery. I had no idea that
one of his best dreams, his happiest
dreams was when he wasn't president and
he wasn't recognized. And that's just a
level of getting to know somebody that I
think makes us like them, makes us
relate to them. And there were moments
throughout the interview, and I'll just
show you a couple where I felt like he
did a really good job of just being real
with us.
Look, I'm owning that completely. I've
always said that that that is probably
the worst mistake of my presidency. Of
course, there are times where I feel
depressed.
Okay.
The bottom line is that he's unafraid to
be vulnerable. And in the age of
authenticity, that's really, really
important. We see that in Berne Brown.
We see that in Simon SK. We see that in
all great communicators. And Barack
shows us that even at the highest level,
the highest title you could have in the
country, there's still an opportunity to
share more of himself with the world.
But that brings us to the final point,
point number four, which is so related,
and that's sense of humor. If you watch
the interview, there's so many times
where Barack is really funny, and it
contrasts so nicely from these more
serious, vulnerable moments to just
moments of light-heartedness. And so, I
created a little compilation of my
favorite bits that really showcase what
type of person Barack Obama is. Let's
take a look.
I'm actually going to lean on you to to
be to be my therapist a little bit. Help
me understand. I'm going to help you
out.
So, meet me here. I'm here speaking on
behalf of so many voters.
First of all, let me let me let me set
my watch so that you know that's part of
the therapy process, right? I know.
So, you know, tell tell your skeptical,
you know, Indian uncles, dude. Come on,
man. The uh that's I I probably helped
Hassan get a job. You know, if if it
hadn't been for another guy with a funny
name, you know, Netflix isn't going to
carry him. Do you have any questions for
me in my body of work?
Not really.
I mean,
copy that.
You know, um maybe shoot a little
higher.
We've seen this from Barack Obama
before. He's been on Between Two Ferns
with Zack Galifanakis. That's an amazing
video to watch. But the point is that
he's just a funny person. That's part of
his personality and he's unafraid to
show it. And that's really the theme of
this video is that at the end of the
day, I think what makes him so likable
or perhaps just so interesting to listen
to is it feels like he is being himself.
There's so many moments where that
happens in the video and I think it
comes down to authenticity. The bottom
line is that communication is a skill
and all of us can learn it and you
already have what it takes. If you're
interested in improving your
communication, there's a free ebook in
the description about how to speak
better under pressure and thrive in the
moment. And at the end of the day,
bottom line, my summary prompt is this.
You already have what it takes to be a
great speaker. So, I hope you continue
on that journey and I'm going to see you
in the next video. Thanks for watching.